the jurogan experience
you spent 200 days in space
in a row i did uh my first flight was
two weeks my second flight was 200 days
that's insane yeah what does that feel
like
um the two weeks was not enough i got
back to earth and i was like man that
was awesome i need to go do this again
uh and after 200 days it was awesome but
it was like all right i checked the box
and
you know i've done every bar done
everything i was a shuttle pilot
you know station commander i did space
walks so i had a chance i feel like i
had a chance to do everything i made a
imax movie while i was up there
i feel like i had a chance to do you
know everything i wanted to do
when you did two weeks is there a
recovery period when you return after
two weeks
yeah for sure but it's pretty quick like
when you land i was super dizzy and i
felt like everything was
heavy i was the last guy out of the
shuttle because i was a pilot and uh
they they came in all right time for
time to get out verts and i grabbed my
helmet and i was like
be careful this thing weighs 500 pounds
and that night i was just like
i wanted someone next to me i didn't
fall over but i felt like i was going to
um but after a day or two i was fine but
after the long duration flight it was
like
that first day sucked i could do
everything i could walk around and
they make you do this torture where you
have to get on your stomach and do it
was like burpees you know get up as fast
you can
they were trying to make you pass out
from orthostatic intolerance so i could
do all that stuff i just
hated it and then the second day was a
little bit better first it was like a
couple bottles of wine
the second day was like a bottle of wine
the third day was like a glass or two
um and by a week later they make you do
this balance test where
they put you in this big box you can't
see anything and then they move the box
and you're like and they have force
sensors on your feet where
if your feet are doing this you know you
have bad balance and if your feet go
and recover you're good so i did my
balance test before flight and after
flight
and after 200 days in space a week later
my balance score was better than it was
before i launched which i couldn't
believe
but um i tell you that story just to say
that you know the human body is amazing
it can adapt
uh pretty quickly that's great so what
is the
like from the time you land after 200
days
and then when you're 100 how much time
is that
so they there's some rule about driving
cars like they don't want you driving
cars for a couple weeks and the doctor's
got to sign off before you drive
oh wow but like i said after a week i
was
i had a better balance score and after a
week i did 20 pull-ups at the gym
i was not 100 but i was like 90 now is
this because of exercises that they
prescribe while you're in space
absolutely yeah what kind of what kind
of stuff do you have to do up there so
they give you two and a half hours a day
the russians learned on mir that your
bone density
it's like a linear progression down you
know about one and a half percent a
month you lose
bone density one and a half percent it's
a straight line it doesn't like bottom
out and they had a guy up there for 440
days he's the most ever time and space
in one mission so to combat that we
exercise
and they found that like pounding uh
resistive exercise is what helps your
bones and your muscles
so we have a weightlifting machine it's
kind of like a bowflex
and a treadmill and a bike and i was
religious about those things i did them
every day
except for my three spacewalk days and
we had this really big emergency or
other than those four days i exercised
every day and are you sweating up there
you sweat a lot when you exercise nor
just doing this you don't sweat at all
you could wear
the same underwear and shirt for weeks
and you don't even notice
but if if you have your exercise shirt
after a day it's like drenched in stinky
like a stinky under armour shirt
because there's no circulation of air
like that
there's not as much well just like if
you go to the gym and you
get out for it for an hour you're going
to be sweating so it's the same thing in
space
but on on norm even if you just walk
around throughout the day
you know you're you can tell you got to
wash your clothes but in space you don't
like for some reason
you just don't stank on normal are they
giving you like merino wool clothes to
wear or something
so we had under armour shirts okay and
after a day or two
it's like they stink and you only got
one shirt every two weeks
oh boy so those things they were ripe
after a couple days
so i did this experiment with wool
clothes like you said it was like a new
zealand company i forgot the name of it
and i was kind of worried because i
didn't want to i thought i'd itch you
know wool
stuff so i wore this thing every day for
a month
got completely drenched sweaty every day
for a month in it
and it did not stink at all like wool is
amazing it's amazing it blew me away
there's a company called first light my
friend steve renell is one of the owners
of it
it's a uh a hunting company and most of
their clothing
particularly all their base layers and
stuff made out of merino wool
and the first time i'd ever worn it was
on a hunting trip yeah you
you realize when you go uh hunting like
one of the big problems is it's freezing
cold out
right but you're hiking with a lot of
gear so you sweat right
and then you have to sit down and freeze
your hypothermia yeah but you don't with
merino wool
and merino wool is wet it still keeps
you warm right and so these guys started
making hunting gear out of it
and it's incredible stuff because it
really doesn't smell
it's so bizarre i sweated drenching
sweat every day for a month and i did
that twice
and it didn't smell at all it blew me
away it's weird yeah i guess it's
organic and the fibers from the wool and
just
for whatever reason it just shakes i
don't know what scientific analysis
they've ever done on it but they can't
really seem to do that with synthetics
they try it with synthetics but they
can't quite
get there you need a you need a washing
machine so did were you the one who
figured that out you brought that stuff
with you
well i mean it was like a formal
experiment you know nasa said that
i was working on mice and doing
astronomy and testing out
new wool fabric it was just one one of
the 250 experiments i did
but it was a good one to do um because i
didn't stink for a couple months which
is that's crazy that even
in space merino wool is the way to go
that's nuts
yeah it i was really worried i was
afraid it was going to be uh
you know itchy but i got like xxl i just
i wanted it loose i didn't want like
wolf rubbing on me but it worked it was
it doesn't itch you think of it as like
being like that
coarse wool that like your grandfather
that just makes you scratchy right
but no they they get it down to where it
feels like cotton it's very soft they
got it figured out man that stuff was
awesome
so when you're using these machines
they're all resistance band
machines is that what it is yeah so the
in the
my book i have a whole uh i make fun of
the acronyms it's a red which is the
nasa acronym for a workout machine
um so it's uses vacuum there's like
tubes
like a cylinder so uh
instead of compressing the air for your
force you're pulling against a vacuum
and you can get the air red machine is
600 pounds
so you can i can't bench or squat 600
pounds but you can put it on there so
you could hurt yourself it's
and the really interesting about these
machines is they they're not attached to
the
wall of the station they're on like
springs and
moving devices they're called vibration
isolation system
because if it was attached think about
like running on a treadmill that's a lot
of pounding you know 200 pounds pounding
um and the earth doesn't really move
that much when you do it on earth but in
space there's nothing
supporting the space station so even
though it's a million pounds
the vibration from exercise would
actually start to
knock it out of orbit not out of orbit
you break it apart actually
what really they told us in a couple
minutes that'll snap it in half yeah
because
the whole thing starts to bend and flex
and if you're doing it in resonance
it's really dangerous they've got videos
of like the the solar rays and these
things are big they don't fit in the
football field they're hundreds of feet
and they start moving and if the
astronaut forgets to
if they leave the if they forget to use
the vibration system
correctly the station starts flexing and
houston there's some guy that monitors
and like the alarm goes off and they
call you up stop doing what you're doing
whoa it kind of blew me away at it it's
a million pound
massive spaceship but still there's
nothing
stopping it there's nothing like
supporting it there's no like
frame no it's just floating so even
the exercise of you running on a
treadmill or you doing squats there's a
lot of
if you're pushing 400 pounds this way
something's pushing 400 pounds that way
right
so um and if you're going up and down in
the right frequency
it'll it'll snap the station in half
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience